We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2 1 9 2.
David, Pete and I. I appreciate this.
This is a voicemail about Joe Biden dropping
out.
OK.
Let's listen to it first and then I'll give
you my thoughts.
Hi, this is Cathy Wood from Illinois.
And I'm wondering, what are our chances of
getting Biden to drop out so we can get a
progressive in there?
I'd like to see Biden.
I mean, excuse me, not Biden.
I'd like to see Bernie Sanders.
My second choice would be Elizabeth Warren.
Want to jump right back on the bottom to drop
out.
My number is 6 3.
Well, OK.
I don't want to put a number out there.
So, listen, I'm getting more and more inquiries
about the Biden drop out movement.
We've got to be realistic.
OK.
Everybody else has ended their campaign and
Biden's winning every poll.
Now, I already saw some some people who don't
seem to understand much of what's going on
on our subreddit saying you can't trust the
polls or the polls were wrong in 2016.
Polls were basically right.
Nationally, they said Hillary would win by
three.
She basically won by three.
But this is not my opinion of whether the
polls are accurate.
What I'm telling you is, look, in history,
when people are winning every poll and everybody
else has dropped out.
They don't end their campaigns.
Now, there are people talking about Biden's
cognitive decline.
There are people talking about the sexual
assault allegation against Biden by terror
Reid from 1993.
There are people just saying, you know, Biden
didn't actually get all the delegates he needs
yet.
Well, but he has more than anybody else.
I think if you're just waiting around thinking
Biden will, quote, come to his senses and
cancel his campaign while he is winning every
poll, you've not paid attention to how history
works unless Biden dies or is in a coma or
something radically new or different happens
that really torpedoes his campaign.
People don't end their campaigns when they're
winning every poll.
He may lose to Donald Trump in November.
Maybe the polls are wrong.
I'm not analyzing the polls.
I'm merely saying the focus on this to me
does not seem like a particularly good use
of time versus lobbying Joe Biden to adopt
more progressive policies.
For example, getting Bernie to ask Joe.
I will, you know, be out there with you every
single day if you can do these two things
to your policy.
And now.
Right.
That seems like a much better use of our time.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about the tax cuts that Donald
Trump wants.
We will talk about a ruling that says New
York will do their Democratic primary.
They were going to cancel it.
And a judge said, no, no, no, you've got to
do it.
We will also talk about restaurant workers
being told, don't wear a face mask, don't
wear a face mask if you or don't work.
That is the choice that in Texas and Dallas,
some reopened restaurant workers are being
told.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Sign ups get instant access at Doyne Pacman
Duck.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.